this episode is brought to you by never
surrender a Galaxy Quest documentary
learn more at fandom not link / never
surrender
[Music]
the fast franchise is as big as ever but
when there's tension in the family a
spin-off will race to hold it together
but hey what's a family without a little
dysfunction some passive aggression and
a crazy uncle who shouldn't be on
Instagram
fast and furious presents Hobbs and sha
remember Hobson Shah neither does this
movie we didn't kill those feds I don't
give a [ __ ] just here to bring in two
[ __ ] whose name's hit my desk I
didn't kill anybody I know you didn't
but meet the rock and Jason Statham
they're the same in every meaningful way
but Shaw is a bit more fancy so they
hate each other's guts and by hate I
mean they've been in love since they got
locked up together and are so scared of
their feelings they hide behind talking
about each other's packages somebody's
overcompensating apologizing and fuss if
it's a little loose align the boss my
top small you stick out like a bull a
bulldog sometimes people annoy each
other when they're actually like see
this girl gets it
watch these two buff testicle cosplays
work together to save the world a
mission no one in the film takes
seriously the planet's population is in
their hands oh cool genocide genocide as
they have to extract the bug of an virus
from Vanessa Kirby who's caught in the
middle of being Shah sister and Hobbes
beard yeah you're not fooling anyone who
talks about sex like he's the 40 old
virgin just so I can do the horizontal
all the sexy sexy time like you grab a
woman's breasts and it feels like a bag
of sand I'm gonna climb this mountain
over and over she'd be like oh you're
nailing me cool prepare for the MCU
vacation of the car movies that were
already pretty ridiculous
but are now full-blown superhero flicks
a black Superman - the origin story that
explains how they're indestructible
because I guess if Marvel is the
blueprint for dominating the box office
just do a Marvel and know the game
that's not your voice use your regular
forces this is my regular voice no
you're not are you making your voice
deeper this is my voice
we've got polemic jaga no this sounds
like a fun game it is to get help
what get help no come on you love it I
hate it
although the rug would know exactly what
to do with a Knossos gauntlet the
decades most overused villain plot has
returned humanity wipes itself out by
2096 but if we fulfill its Young's
vision gosh again ah
strap in as the boys take on a shady
tech called
with the power to control the media and
shape public opinion that operates in a
secretive headquarters with an open
floor plan Facebook I mean anti-iran but
instead of punching Mark Zuckerberg
they'll punch a much stronger evil robot
idris elba and his best friend
motorcycle he's a human machine hybrid
who can hack into the soundtrack and
force us to listen to him wrap over the
chasey
but this Terminator has just one
weakness to guys at the same time is
this the movie or the slash Bank I can't
tell anymore so gear up for the latest
chapter in the fast rise that seems more
GI Joe than Toretto but has enough fast
cars furious faces and flashy BOTS to
check all the right boxes because when
you get the rock Statham and one of the
John wick directors you're gonna get a
tight action-packed 90-minute summer
blockbuster with an extra 45 minutes at
it on because the rock wanted to take a
trip to Samoa starring dwayne the vin
diesel in my the same age is Jason
Statham's character okay
fell and mirin Russian super criminal
Eliza Gonzales okay stronger bail dis
Roman reigns have a best cause at all
his contracts there are no small parts
only small actors pebbles that basement
that spies use and special agent Pikachu
Bravo a car war story that's exactly why
I hate working with you because he
killed Han and like dozens of other
innocent people it's your voice huh
thanks for watching by grabthar's hammer
click the Box on the left to learn more
about never surrender then I'll be home
just in time for cornflakes where's the
Twinkies are you wearing space pants
because your butt is out of this world